maligayang pagbabalik sa pag-unawa sa Quantum na impormasyon at komputasyon, ang pangalan ko ay John Matus at ako ang technical director para sa edukasyon sa IBM
Quantum ito ang ika-12 na aralin sa serye at ito ang huling aralin sa ikatlong yunit na tungkol sa pangkalahatang
pormulasyon ng quantum na impormasyon ang araling ito ay nakasentro sa isang pundamental na konsepto sa Quantum na impormasyon na siyang tinatawag na
purification ng isang Quantum State ang purification ng isang Quantum State na kinakatawan ng isang density Matrix ay isang
pure state ng isang mas malaking compound system na nagbibigay sa atin ng orihinal na estado kapag ang natitirang bahagi ng compound system ay
tinapon o ni-trace out bawat density Matrix ay may purification at marami tayong matututunan
tungkol sa Quantum States at tungkol sa Quantum na impormasyon sa pangkalahatan sa pamamagitan ng pag-aaral ng mga purification sa isang intuitive na antas
Ang mga Quantum State vector na kumakatawan sa mga pure state ay mas simpleng mathematical na bagay kaysa sa mga density matrix at sa pamamagitan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa
mga purification ng mga estado, kaya nating tingnan ang mga arbitrary na Quantum state ng mga sistema bilang bahagi lamang ng isang mas malaki ngunit
mas simpleng bagay pag-uusapan din natin ang Fidelity sa pagitan ng dalawang Quantum state na isang halaga na nagkukuantipika ng kanilang
pagkakatulad o overlap at madalas itong ginagamit bilang paraan ng pagsukat kung gaano kagaling ang isang partikular na estado kumpara sa
ilang ideal na estado sa partikular, tatalakayin natin ang depinisyon ng fidelity kasama ang ilan sa mga pangunahing katangian nito at makikita natin
kung paano kumonekta ang Fidelity sa mga purification narito ang isang pangkalahatang-ideya ng aralin magsisimula tayo sa mga purification kabilang ang
depinisyon at isang simpleng patunay ng kanilang pagkakaroon na nagsasabi sa atin kung paano mahanap ang isa kapag kailangan natin ito pagkatapos ay tatalakayin natin ang isang bagay na kilala
bilang Schmid decomposition ng isang Quantum State Vector ng dalawang sistema at makikita natin kung paano nag-uugnay ang mga Schmid decomposition sa
mga purification pagkatapos ay tatalakayin natin ang isang kritikal na mahalagang relasyon sa pagitan ng anumang dalawang purification ng parehong estado na kilala bilang unitary
equivalence ng mga purification at sa wakas ay dadaan tayo sa ilang halimbawa pagkatapos ay lumipat tayo sa Fidelity
kabilang ang depinisyon nito at ilan sa mga pangunahing katangian nito pag-uusapan natin ang gentle measurement Lemma na isang napaka-
maginhawang katotohanan na nag-uugnay sa Fidelity pabalik sa mga sukat at sa wakas upang tapusin ang aralin ay lilipat tayo sa teorema ni man na
nagtatag ng pundamental na koneksyon sa pagitan ng Fidelity at ng mga purification simulan natin sa
depinisyon ng isang purification ang purification ng isang estado na ipinapalagay ay kinakatawan ng isang density
Matrix ay isang pure state ng isang mas malaking compound system na nagbibigay ng orihinal na estado na sinimulan natin nang ang natitirang bahagi
ng compound system ay na-trace out maaari nating ipahayag ito nang mas tiyak sa mathematical na mga termino bilang
mga sumusunod kung mayroon tayong sistema X na nasa ilang Estado row ibig sabihin ang row ay isang density Matrix na kumakatawan sa isang estado ng X
at ang S ay isang Quantum State Vector ng isang pares ng mga sistema XY tulad na ang pag-trace out ng y mula sa pure State C side bro plus I
ay nagbibigay sa atin ng row pagkatapos ay sinasabi nating ang s ay isang purification ng row natural ang mga pangalan ay hindi mahalaga
maaari nating pangalanan ang ating mga sistema at ang ating mga estado anuman ang gusto natin at ang pagkakasunud-sunod ng mga sistema ay hindi rin mahalaga halimbawa
kung ang sistema y ay nasa kaliwa kaysa sa kanan ngunit ang lahat ng iba ay pareho ay matatawag pa rin nating ang SAI bilang isang purification ng row ngunit
mananatili tayo sa setup na ito para sa natitirang bahagi ng aralin para lamang sa kapakanan ng Simplisidad at ang unang bagay na dapat sabihin
tungkol sa depinisyon ay palagi itong umiiral para sa bawat density Matrix row at upang maging mas tiyak bawat density
Matrix row ay may purification tulad ng inilalarawan ng depinisyon sa kondisyon na ang sistema y ay hindi bababa sa kasingliit ng X na
ibig sabihin ang y ay may hindi bababa sa kasingyaman ng mga classical State gaya ng X ang konsepto ng purification at ang
katotohanan na ang mga purification ay palaging umiiral ay napakahalaga at ito rin ay bahagi ng kung ano ang nagpapaganda ng Quantum na impormasyon at sana ay
makukumbinsi ko kayo sa katotohanang iyon bago matapos ang aralin ngayon patunayan natin na ang bawat density matrix ay may purification at sa
proseso ay makikita natin kung paano natin makuha ang isang purification kapag kailangan natin ito tulad ng nasa depinisyon
ng isang purification ipagpalagay natin na ang X ay isang sistema at ang row ay isang density Matrix na kumakatawan sa isang estado ng
X ngayon isaalang-alang ang anumang pagpapahayag ng row bilang isang convex combination ng mga pure state tulad ng nakasulat namin sa screen sa mga salita
para sa ilang pagpili ng isang positibong integer n mayroon kaming isang probability Vector p 0 hanggang PN minus 1 pati na rin ang Quantum
State vectors 5 0 hanggang 5 nus isa at sa pamamagitan ng pag-average ng kaukulang mga pure state na may timbang ng mga probabilidad
nakuha natin ang Row halimbawa maaari tayong gumamit ng spectral theorem upang makakuha ng isang pagpapahayag ng row tulad nito at kung gagawin natin iyon
maaari nating kunin ang n bilang bilang ng mga classical state ng X sa katunayan maaari nating kunin ang n bilang rank ng row na
katumbas ng bilang ng mga hindi-zero na won value ng row kung bilangin ang bawat isa ng ilang beses na katumbas ng multiplicity nito at
iyon ay hindi kailanman mas malaki kaysa sa bilang ng mga classical state ng X ngunit maaari itong maging mas maliit sa kabilang banda hindi ito
kailangang maging isang spectral decomposition ng row at hindi natin kailangan ang mga Quantum State vector na ito na maging orthogonal halimbawa anumang pagpapahayag ng row tulad nito
ay okay at narito ang isang purification ng row ang kabuuan ay umaabot sa parehong mga halaga gaya ng
sa ating pagpapahayag ng row at sa loob ng kabuuan kinukuha natin ang mga square root ng mga probabilidad na pinarami sa F A tensored
kasama ang k a dito sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay ipinapalagay natin na ang 0 hanggang n minus isa ay mga classical state ng pangalawang sistema y kaya
makatuwirang ang s ay isang Quantum State Vector ng pares XY tulad ng sa depinisyon hindi talaga mahalaga
dito na gumamit tayo ng standard basis state ng Y sa pagpapahayag na ito maaari kang mag-substitute ng anumang orthonormal na koleksyon ng
mga estado sa lugar ng K 0 hanggang Kat n minus isa kung gusto mo at ngayon maaari nating suriin na ito ay talagang
isang purification sa pamamagitan ng Pagkalkula ng partial Trace sa y narito ang isang pagpapahayag ng estado na makuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pagsasagawa ng partial trace
ang trace ng k a bra B ay isa o zero depende sa kung ang a ay katumbas ng B o hindi at kaya ang pagpapahayag
ay nasisimplipika sa ating orihinal na pagpapahayag ng row at napakasimple nito kaya madali tayong makakakuha ng
purification basta mayroon tayong sapat na mga classical state ng Y o alternatibo ay sapat na malaking orthonormal na set na gagamitin
sa halip ng standard Bas ng States cat 0 hanggang cat n minus isa at sa pamamagitan ng paraan kung ang bilang ng
mga classical state ng Y ay mas maliit kaysa sa rank ng row kung gayon ay wala nang purification at iiwan ko iyon para sa inyo
na pag-isipan kung pipiliin mong gawin iyon narito ang isang halimbawa isaalang-alang natin
ang density Matrix na nakita natin ng ilang beses sa aralin tungkol sa density matrices narito ay mayroon tayong isang pagpapahayag ng
density Matrix na ito bilang isang convex combination ng mga pure state hindi ito isang spectral decomposition ngunit hindi natin
pinapansin iyon at halos walang pagsisikap maaari tayong sumulat ng isang purification ng estado sa pamamagitan ng pagsunod sa
recipe iyon ay hindi ang tanging purification ng density Matrix na ito ang mga purification ay hindi natatangi ngunit okay lang iyon ang
depinisyon ay hindi nagsasabi ng anumang bagay tungkol sa kakaibaan at sa katunayan ay may napaka-interesanteng relasyon sa pagitan ng iba't ibang purification ng parehong estado ngunit
tatalakayin natin iyon nang kaunti mamaya sa aralin susunod ay isasaalang-alang natin ang mga Schmid decomposition na mga pagpapahayag ng
bipartite quantum State vector sa isang tiyak na anyo na ilalarawan ko ngayon pinangalanan sila kay aard
Schmidt ang parehong Schmid na kilala para sa Graham Schmid orthogonalization procedure ngunit sa kaso ng mga Schmid decomposition marahil ay hindi sila dapat
mapangalanan kay Schmidt ito ay talagang mathematically equivalent sa isang bagay na tinatawag na singular value decomposition para sa mga matrix na isang bagay na
talagang na-rediscover nang maraming beses ngunit nangyayari iyon minsan ngunit sa anumang paraan narito ang ibig nating sabihin
kapag tinutukoy natin ang isang Schmid decomposition para sa isang arbitrary na pagpili ng isang Quantum State Vector s para sa isang pares ng
mga sistema XY palagi itong posible na isulat ang s sa isang espesyal na anyo na ang anyo ay tulad ng
nasa screen natin dito kung saan ang R ay ilang positibong integer ang p 0 hanggang p r minus isa ay mga positibong tunay na numero na
magkasamang bumubuo ng isang probability Vector x0 hanggang XR minus 1 ay mga unit vector na naaayon sa sistema X at y0
hanggang y rus 1 ay mga unit vector na naaayon sa sistema y ngayon maaaring hindi iyon mukhang partikular na
espesyal hanggang sa sabihin ko sa inyo na ang parehong mga set x0 hanggang XR minus isa at y0 hanggang y Rus isa ay dapat na
orthonormal kaya bakit iyon espesyal kung pipili tayo ng anumang basis para sa isa sa dalawang basis halimbawa
ang mga X vector na naaayon sa sistema X maaari nating palaging ipahayag ang s sa form na ito at pipelitin tayong
pumili ng mga Y vector sa isang partikular na paraan sa katunayan ginagawa natin ito medyo regular tulad ng ginagawa natin sa isang standard basis kapag
nagse-set up tayo para suriin ang isang standard basis measurement ngunit sa pangkalahatan kahit piliin natin ang isang orthonormal basis para sa X
vectors ang mga Y vector na makuha natin ay hindi kinakailangang magiging orthonormal katulad kung pipili ka ng
isang orthonormal basis para sa mga Y vector at susubukan mong ipahayag ang s sa anyo muli magagawa mo ngunit muli ang mga X vector ay hindi
kinakailangang magiging orthonormal at sa wakas kung pumili ka ng orthonormal na mga vector para sa parehong sistema at
subukan mong ipahayag ang s sa isang anyo tulad nito ay hindi kinakailangang gagana ito dahil maaaring makita mo na kailangan mo ng ilang cross term ngunit mayroon lamang
isang index sa kabuuan na ito na ang a kaya ang anyo ay espesyal ngunit lagi itong posible na
isulat ang isang ibinigay na unit Vector s tulad nito at narito kung paano mo ito magagawa una ay kalkulahin ang isang spectral decomposition
para sa reduced state ng alinman sa dalawang sistema hindi mahalaga kung alin ngunit para sa kapakanan ng paglalarawan kung paano ito ginagawa tingnan natin ang reduced state ng
X kaya tinatrace natin ang y na ibig sabihin ang p 0 hanggang p r minus isa ay mga eigen
value ng reduced State row na ito at x0 hanggang XR minus isa ay mga unit eigen vector na naaayon sa mga eigen value na ito at sa
pamamagitan ng paraan ang pag-unawa dito ay hindi namin pinapansin ang mga termino kung saan ang mga eigen value ay zero dahil ang mga terminong iyon ay hindi nag-aambag ng anumang bagay sa
kabuuan at ibig sabihin nito ang p 0 hanggang p r minus isa ay lahat ng positibong tunay na numero at ang R ay ang bilang ng mga hindi-zero
eigen value na may multiplicities na katumbas ng rank ng row kaya nagbibigay ito sa atin ng p 0 hanggang p r
minus isa pati na rin ang x0 hanggang XR minus isa at ang natitira lamang ay ang paghanap ng mga vector y0 hanggang y Rus
isa mayroon lamang isang pagpipilian na maaaring gumana ang mga vector na iyon ay natatanging natutukoy sa puntong ito at maaari
silang madaling mahanap gamit ang simpleng formula na ipinapakita sa screen at ang kamangha-manghang bagay dito ay na
kung ine-define natin ang mga vector na ito sa ganitong paraan kung gayon ay garantisadong magiging orthonormal ang mga ito at nagbibigay ito sa atin ng isang Schmid decomposition hindi ko ito tatalakayin sa
video na ito ngunit hindi ito masyadong mahirap at maaari kang kumonsulta sa nakasulat na materyal para sa aralin kung interesado ka suriin
ang paglalarawan ng video para sa isang link tulad ng dati bilang isang halimbawa isaalang-alang natin ang
Quantum State Vector na ito na nakuha natin bilang isang purification ng halimbawa ng density Matrix na patuloy nating binabalik sa
hindi ito isang Schmid decomposition dahil ang zero at plus na mga estado ay hindi orthonormal ngunit maaari tayong makahanap ng isa
gamit ang pamamaraan na katatapos ko lamang ilarawan ang unang hakbang ay ang kalkulahin ang isang spectral decomposition para sa reduced
state ng X na siyang parehong halimbawa ng isang density Matrix at narito ang isang spectral decomposition nito na nakita natin noong
aralin 9 kaya pipiliin natin ang p 0 P1 x0 at X1 tulad ng
ipinapakita sa screen ang p 0 at P1 ay mga eigen value ng row at x0 at X1 ay
kaukulang unit eigen vector kaya nananatili ang pagkalkula ng y0 at y1 at kung gagawin natin ito makuha natin ang cat Plus
para sa y0 at -1 * Kat minus para sa y1 hindi iyon agad ang kailangan mong
talagang gawin ang kalkulasyon upang makita ito ngunit iyon ang makuha natin at gaya ng inaasahan ang dalawang vector na iyon ay orthonormal tulad ng
palagi silang magiging kung tama ang iyong mga kalkulasyon at nagbibigay ito sa atin ng isang Schmid decomposition
Ang mga Schmid decomposition ay napaka-maginhawa sa maraming sitwasyon at sa lalong madaling panahon ay makikita natin kung ano ang sinasabi nila sa atin
tungkol sa mga purification ang mga purification ay hindi natatangi ang isang ibinigay na Quantum State na kinakatawan
ng isang density Ma ay talagang magkakaroon ng walang hanggang maraming purification gayunpaman ay mayroong isang malapit na
relasyon na palaging nananatili sa pagitan ng anumang dalawang purification ng parehong estado at minsan ay tinatawag itong unitary
equivalence ng mga purification narito kung paano ito gumagana hayaan ang row na maging isang density Matrix
na kumakatawan sa isang Quantum state ng isang sistema X at ipagpalagay na mayroon kaming anumang dalawang purification ng estado na iyon na
mga pure state ng parehong compound system kaya para sa kapakanan ng kongkretong halimbawa ipagpalagay na ang s at fi
ay mga quantum State vector ng isang pares ng mga sistema XY na parehong nagbibigay sa atin ng row kapag ang sistema Y ay na-trace
out ang sinasabi ng unitary equivalence ng purification ay na dapat may isang unitary operation U na kumikilos lamang sa
sistema y na nag-transform ng SII sa fi sa ibang salita kahit na ang mga ito ay
mga arbitrary na purification ng row at wala tayong ipinapalagay tungkol sa kanila maliban sa parehong nag-purify ng row at sila ay
parehong estado ng parehong compound system XY kailangan nilang maging katumbas sa ilang kahulugan hanggang sa isang unitary operation sa y
nag-iisa makakakita tayo ng ilang halimbawa na naglalarawan kung bakit ito kawili-wili at kung anong mga implikasyon ang mayroon ito ngunit una ay
tingnan natin kung bakit ito totoo simulan natin sa isang spectral decomposition ng row na siyang
density Matrix na parehong ini-purify ng SII at fi at tulad ng ginawa natin nang tinalakay natin ang Schmid decomposition
ipagpalagay natin na itinapon na natin ang lahat ng termino na naaayon sa zero eigen value kaya ang p 0 hanggang p r minus 1
ay lahat ng positibong tunay na numero x0 hanggang XR minus isa ay orthonormal eigen vector ng row at ang R ay ang
rank ng row at sa pamamagitan ng paraan tulad ng isang pag-uusap pansinin kung gaano kadalas nating inaabot ang spectral theorem sa puntong ito
ito ay isang napaka-maginhawang kasangkapan at sa katunayan ay maliligaw tayo nang wala ito sa anumang paraan ngayong mayroon na tayong spectral
composition ng row maaari tayong kalkulahin ang mga Schmid decomposition ng ating dalawang vector tulad ng dati at sila ay magiging
halos eksakto pareho ang mga coefficient at mga X vector ay pareho dahil nagmumula sila sa spectral decomposition ng reduced state na
pareho para sa parehong vector ang tanging pagkakaiba ay maaari tayong makakuha ng iba't ibang vector para sa pangalawang sistema para sa
unang Vector na s makakakuha tayo ng isang set ng mga vector y0 hanggang y Rus isa at para sa pangalawang Vector na f makakakuha tayo ng
marahil na iba't ibang koleksyon na maaari nating tawaging z0 hanggang zrus isa kaya mayroon na tayong schmitti composition
para sa ating dalawang vector na magkahawig maliban sa mga vector para sa pangalawang sistema ay maaaring iba ngunit ang mga ito ay
mga Schmitty composition kaya ang dalawang koleksyon na ito ay parehong orthonormal at kaya maaari tayong pumili ng
isang unitary Matrix U na nagpapadala ng ya sa Za para sa bawat a palagi mong magagawa iyon ang unitary
operations ay talagang katumbas ng mga linear map na nag-transform ng isang orthonormal basis sa isa pa at kung
ang dalawang set na ito ay hindi sumasaklaw sa buong espasyo na naaayon sa Y maaari nating palaging palawakin ang parehong sa orthonormal
Bases gamit ang kahanga-hangang gr Schmid orthogonalization procedure at iyon ang kung paano napatunayan ang unitary
equivalence ng mga purification sa aralin apat ng serye tinalakay natin ang superdense coding protocol
na nagpapahintulot sa isang nagpadala na maipasa ang dalawang classical bit sa isang tatanggap sa pamamagitan ng pagpapadala ng isang cubit sa gastos ng isang ebit ng
shared entanglement kaya ipinapalagay ko na pamilyar ka na sa protocol na iyon at ang layunin ng halimbawang ito ay maigsi na
ipaliwanag kung paano ito kumokonekta sa unitary equivalence ng mga purification alalahanin na ang paraan ng
protocol ay gumagana ay ang Alice at Bob ay nagbabahagi ng isang ebit o sa ibang salita ay isang five plus Bell State pipiliin ni Alice na i-transform iyon
Bell State sa alinman sa Apat na Bell State depende sa dalawang bit na gusto niyang ipadala at pagkatapos ay nagpapadala siya ng kaniyang
Cubit kay Bob at sinusukat niya upang makita kung aling Bell State ang mayroon siya pansinin na ang lahat ng apat na bell State
ay nagbibigay sa atin ng parehong reduced state para sa Cubit ni Bob na siyang completely mixed state at sa katunayan iyon ay sapat na
upang mapatibay na posible ang super dense cating ang lahat ng apat na bell State ay nag-purify ng completely mixed state kaya sa unitary
equivalence ng mga purification alam natin na dapat ay posible para kay Alice na i-transform ang five plus Bell State sa
isa sa iba sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng ilang unitary operation sa kaniyang Cubit siyempre ay hindi mahirap na makabuo ng mga unitary operation na
talagang gumagana at napaka-simple ng mga ito ngunit kapaki-pakinabang pa rin na maaari tayong maabot ang konklusyon na ito ay
posible nang hindi man lang inisip ang tungkol sa mga unitary operation mismo at bukod pa rito ay maaari tayong mapatibay
na posible ang mga pagpapalawak ng superdense coding sa mas malalaking sistema basta mayroon tayong paraan ng pagpapalawak ng mga Bell state sa mas malalaking
sistema upang lahat sila ay magbigay ng completely mix State bilang reduced State ni Bob at mayroon sa katunayan ng iba't ibang kilalang paraan upang gawin
iyon ang ibang setting kung saan may mga implikasyon ang unitary equivalence ng mga purification ay quantum
cryptography at isa sa pinakamahalaga nitong implikasyon ay nag-aalas ito ng pagkakaroon ng isang walang kondisyong ligtas na Quantum protocol para sa isang
cryptographic primitive na kilala bilang bit commitment kaya ano ang bit commitment ang bit commitment ay isang halimbawa
ng isang cryptographic ative na ibig nating sabihin ay isang mababang antas na gawain o pamamaraan na nagbibigay ng ilang pangunahing functionality na
maaaring gamitin bilang isang building block upang gumawa ng mas kawili-wiling mga bagay tulad ng paglikha ng mga digital signature scheme o pagtatayo ng
mga zero knowledge protocol halimbawa sa kaso ng bit commitment ang pangunahing functionality ay na ang isa
manlalaro na si Alice ay kayang mag-commit sa isang binary value ng kaniyang pagpili sa isang pangalawang manlalaro na si Bob ngunit ang kaniyang pagpili ay nananatiling nakatago
hanggang sa piliing ibunyag niya ito nangangailangan tayo ng dalawang partikular na katangian mula sa isang protocol na nagpapatupad ng bit
commitment dapat itong maging binding na ibig sabihin ay hindi mababago ni Alice ang isip niya kapag nag-commit na siya sa isang bit at ito
ay dapat na concealing na ibig sabihin ay hindi matutukoy ni Bob ang bit ni Alice hanggang sa piliing ibunyag niya
ito kaya magiging napakaganda na makagamit ng Quantum na impormasyon para ma-implement ang primitive na ito dahil ito ay isang
kapaki-pakinabang na primitive ngunit nang walang anumang karagdagang pagpapalagay ay lumalabas na imposible ang gawin ito nang perpekto gamit ang Quantum na impormasyon o kahit malapit
nang perpekto at ang unitary equivalence ng mga purification ay nagpapakita na ang ideya sa isang napataas na antas ay
kung mayroon sana ay isang Quantum protocol para sa bit commitment pagkatapos ay kailangang magkaroon ng isang tinatawag na purified na bersyon ng protocol na iyon kung saan maaari nating isipin na
si Alice ay may sistema a si Bob ay may sistema B at pagkatapos ng commitment ay ginawa ngunit bago ibunyag ni Alice ang pares AB ay nasa
isa sa dalawang pure State size zero o I isa depende sa bit na
ini-commit ni Alice kung ang protocol ay perpektong concealing pagkatapos ay dapat hindi matukoy ni Bob ang pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng
dalawang commitment kaya ang kaniyang reduced state ay dapat na pareho para sa dalawang posibilidad gayunpaman ay nagpapahiwatig iyon sa pamamagitan ng
unitary equivalence ng mga purification na maaaring i-transform ni Alice ang alinman sa isa patungo sa isa pa sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng ilang unitary
operation sa a nang mag-isa kaya ang protocol ay ganap na nabigo sa pagiging binding may mga detalye doon na
tinapon ko sa ilalim ng ruga ngunit ang puso ng bagay ay ang unitary equivalence ng mga purification ay nagsasabi sa atin na ang primitive na ito ay hindi isang bagay
na maaari nating maaasahang i-implement gamit ang Quantum na impormasyon nang walang karagdagang pagpapalagay ng ilang
uri ang huling halimbawa ng isang implikasyon ng unitary equivalence ng mga purification ay isang teorema na kilala bilang
Houston Joseph wooders theorem o hjw theorem para sa maikli simulan natin sa pahayag ng
teorema mismo at ito ay isang bahagyang pinasimpleng bersyon nito upang maiwasan ang ilang teknikal na detalye upang makapagtuon tayo sa pangunahing
mga ideya ipagpalagay na ang X at Y ay mga sistema at ang F ay anumang Quantum State Vector na kumakatawan sa isang pure state ng pares
XY at ngayon ay ipagpalagay nating iniisip natin ang reduced state ng sistema X nag-iisa at naghahanap tayo ng anumang paraan na
pipiliin nating ipahayag ang reduced State na ito bilang isang convex combination ng mga pure state tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen
halimbawa ang bilang na capital N sa pagpapahayag na ito na siyang bilang ng mga pure state na ina-average natin ay maaaring
maging arbitraryong malaki marahil ay mas malaki kaysa sa dimensyon ng espasyo na naaayon sa X o sa Y para sa
bagay na iyon at ang sinasabi sa atin ng teorema ay dapat ay mayroon isang sukat sa sistema y na may n resulta upang
mangyari ang sumusunod kapag nasukat ang sistema Y una ang bawat resulta ng sukat
ay lumalabas na may probabilidad na eksaktong katumbas ng kaukulang probabilidad sa ating pagpapahayag ng reduced state ng X bilang
isang convex combination ng mga pure state at pangalawa ay naka-kondisyon sa pagkuha ng isang partikular na resulta ng sukat ang
estado ng X ay nagiging ang kaukulang pure state mula sa convex combination kaya bakit iyon
kawili-wili ibig sabihin nito na para sa anumang paraan ng pag-iisip natin tungkol sa reduced state ng X bilang isang convex
combination ng mga pure state mayroong ilang sukat ng Y na epektibong ginagawang katotohanan ang paraang ito ng pag-iisip tungkol sa reduced state ng x
at ang kahanga-hangang bagay ay posible ito kahit ang estado f ay pinili muna at ang convex
combination ay pinili mamaya basta ito ay isang pagpapahayag ng reduced state ng X magkakaroon ng
sukat ng Y na gumagana nang ganito kaya tingnan natin kung paano natin mapatunayan
ito nagsisimula tayo sa dalawang iba't ibang pagpapahayag para sa reduced ng X na bibigyan ng pangalan na Row para sa
kaginhawaan susunod ay nagpapakilala tayo ng isang bagong sistema Z na ang mga classical state ay ang mga posibleng resulta ng sukat o
katumbas nito ang mga index sa ating convex combination at ngayon ay maaari nating masundan na ang sumusunod na dalawang Quantum State vector
gamma 0 at Gamma 1 na parehong estado vector para sa compound system XYZ ay
parehong purification ng row at upang maging malinaw kapag iniisip natin ang tungkol sa mga vector na ito bilang mga ification ng row
iniisip natin ang tungkol sa mga sistema Y at Z magkasama bilang isang compound system na na-trace out upang maiwan ang
Row ang unang Vector gamma 0er ay karaniwang parehong bagay gaya ng orihinal na pure State 5 maliban na ini-initialize natin ang bagong sistema Z sa zero State malinaw na kung i-trace natin ang Y at Z mananatili tayong may row kaya ang gamma
0er ay isang purification ng row ang pangalawang Vector Gamma 1 ay karaniwang ang vector na makuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pag-purify ng
row batay sa convex combination tulad ng inilarawan ko kanina sa aralin sa pagkakataong ito ang sistema Y ay
ini-initialize at ipinagpapalagay ko lamang para sa Simplisidad na ang zero ay isang classical state ng Y ngunit maaari kang mag-substitute ng anumang
standard basis state o sa katunayan ay anumang pure state ng Y sa pagpapahayag na ito at hindi ito gagawa ng anumang pagkakaiba sa anumang kaso ang pag-trace out ng Y at
Z muli ay nagbibigay sa atin ng row kaya ang bottom line ay ang mga ito ay parehong purification ng row at samakatuwid sa pamamagitan ng
unitary equivalence ng mga purification ay mayroon isang unitary operation U sa pares YZ na nag-transform ng gamma 0 sa
Gamma 1 at iyon lamang ang kailangan natin upang makabuo ng isang paglalarawan ng sukat na ginagawa ang sinasabi ng teorema
isang simpleng paraan upang ilarawan ito ay gamit ang isang circuit diagram tulad ng ipinapakita dito sa screen sa mga salita ay nagsisimula tayo sa
estado F nagpapakilala tayo ng Z na ini-initialize sa zero State ginagawa ang U at pagkatapos ay sinusukat ang nangungunang sistema na siyang Z gamit ang isang
standard basis measurement epektibong ang ginagawa nito ay ang i-transform ang fi sa Gamma One at
sa pamamagitan lamang ng pagtingin sa paglalarawan ng Gamma 1 ay makikita natin na ginagawa nito ang sinasabi ng teorema na nakakakuha tayo ng
bawat resulta a na may probabilidad PA at naka-kondisyon sa pagkuha ng a ang sistema X ay nananatili sa estado sa
a at upang maging malinaw ang sukat mismo na ipinahihiwatig ng pagkakaroon ng teorema ay ipinapatupad ng
lahat ng bagay sa may tuldok na parihaba sa figure at kung gusto mong malaman kung paano ang
sukat ay maaaring ilarawan bilang isang koleksyon ng mga matrix narito ang isang pagpapahayag ng mga ito hindi ko ipapaliwanag ang bahaging ito at ito ay
hindi talaga mahalaga para sa kapakanan ng halimbawa ngunit iyon ay isang pagpapahayag ng mga measurement matrix kung interesado ka
susunod ay tatalakayin natin ang Fidelity na isang sukatan ng kung gaano katulad ang dalawang Quantum state o alternatibo kung gaano
karami ang overlap nila magsisimula tayo sa depinisyon na maaaring mukhang kaunting misteryoso sa
unang tingin ngunit ibibitin natin ito at bago matapos ang talakayan ay umaasa akong makukumbinsi ko kayo na ito ay
talagang isang mas magandang function kaysa sa maaaring mukhang sa unang tingin at narito ang
depinisyon ang Fidelity sa pagitan ng dalawang density matrices row at sigma ay katumbas ng trace ng square root ng
square root ng row * Sigma oras ang square root ng row pag-uusapan natin
ito una subukan nating bigyan ng kahulugan ang depinisyon mismo mayroon kaming tatlong square root at
lahat sila ay tumutukoy sa square root ng isang positive semi-definite Matrix na tulad ng tinalakay natin sa nakaraang aralin ay
ang natatanging positive semi-definite Matrix na nagsi-square upang bigyan tayo ng anumang Matrix na kinukuha natin ang square root dahil
ang row ay isang density Matrix ito ay dapat na positive semi-definite kaya maaari nating kunin ang root nito at kung iniisip natin ang theot ng row *
Sigma theot ng row nang sandali ay makikita natin na ito ay positive semi-definite din at sa partikular ay maaari nating isulat ito bilang
mger * M para sa M na siyang sare root ng Sigma oras ng sare root ng row at samakatuwid ay maaari tayong kumuha ng square
root nito sa partikular ay maaari tayong kalkulahin ang isang spectral decomposition ng root ng
row * Sigma * theun ng row at pagkatapos ay upang kumuha ng square root ay kailangan lamang nating kunin ang mga square root ng mga eigen
value at iwanan ang mga eigen vector nang mag-isa at sa wakas ay kinukuha natin ang trace ng
Matrix na ito at dahil ang trace ay katumbas ng kabuuan ng mga eigen value ay nakuha natin ang pagpapahayag na mayroon tayo ngayon dito
kaya iyon ay marahil ay isang bagay na hindi mo gustong kalkulahin sa pamamagitan ng kamay sa pangkalahatan at ang paliwanag na ito ay maaaring hindi
nagbibigay ng maraming kaalaman tungkol sa Fidelity o kung bakit kami nagmamalasakit dito ngunit sana ay nilinaw nito ang teknikal na
kahulugan ng formula sa pamamagitan ng paraan tulad ng isang pag-uusap minsan tinutukoy ng mga tao ang Fidelity bilang
ang square ng function na inilarawan ko ngayon dito at tinutukoy nila ang function na ito bilang root
Fidelity makikita mo itong nai-define sa parehong paraan na tiyak ay may potensyal na magdulot ng kalituhan ngunit karaniwang hindi
ito nangyayari dahil ang mga tao ay karaniwang maingat na nagpapalinaw kung aling depinisyon ang kanilang ginagamit at dapat
kang siguraduhing gawin ang parehong bagay sa aking pagtingin ay talagang walang tama o maling depinisyon ini-define ko ito
tulad nito dahil lamang sanay na akong gawin ito sa ganitong paraan at sa tingin ko ay kaunti itong mas maginhawa siguro dahil mas gusto kong i-square
ang isang bagay kaysa sa kumuha ng square root mamaya kapag lumabas ang pangangailangan ngunit siyempre ay malaya kang gumawa ng iyong sariling
pagpili ngunit sa anumang paraan hayaan akong bumalik sa Fidelity tulad ng inilarawan dito mayroong iba pang katumbas na mga paraan ng
pag-define ng Fidelity at ito ay talagang isang napaka-kahanga-hangang function sa bagay na iyon at maaari itong talagang mapakilala sa ilang medyo kawili-wiling
paraan narito ang isang medyo diretso na paraan ng muling pagsulat ng depinisyon sa mga termino ng trace Norm na nakita natin sa bandang
dulo ng nakaraang aralin hindi ako nagpunta nang masyadong malalim sa trace norm at sa partikular ay
hindi ko man lang ini-define ito para sa mga non-h herian matrix ngunit mayroon itong sapat na simpleng depinisyon isang paraan ng pag-define ng trace Norm ng isang
arbitrary Matrix m ay ang trace ng square root ng M * m dagger o katumbas nito ang trace ng sare
root ng M dagger oras ng M makakakuha ka ng parehong halaga sa alinmang paraan mo ito gawin at maaari nating gamitin ang depinisyong iyon upang pasimplehin ang
depinisyon ng Fidelity tulad ng nasa ibaba ng screen at maganda iyon dahil inihahayag nito na
ito ay simetriko sa dalawang argumento maaari rin nating ipahayag ang trace Norm ng isang square Matrix m bilang ang
maximum ng absolute value ng trace ng M * U sa lahat ng unary matrices U na hindi halatang totoo ngunit ito
ay totoo at nagbibigay ito sa atin ng isa pang pagpapahayag para sa Fidelity kaya narito mayroon tayong tatlong
katumbas na mga depinisyon para sa Fidelity at iyon ay simula pa lamang mayroong ilang iba pang katumbas na mga depinisyon at
makikita natin ang isang partikular na mahalaga na nagmumula sa teorema ni man sa bandang dulo ng aralin
okay kaya okay iyon ngunit ano ang ibig sabihin nito sa isang intuitive na antas at bakit dapat nating pangalagaan ang
function upang sagutin ang mga tanong na ito ay nakatutulong na isaalang-alang ang espesyal na kaso kung saan hindi bababa sa isa sa dalawang density
matrix ay kumakatawan sa isang pure state kung ang parehong estado ay pure pagkatapos ang
Fidelity ay simpleng absolute value ng inner product sa pagitan ng dalawang Quantum State vector at sa ilang paraan
ito ang pangunahing motibasyon para sa Fidelity mismo ang absolute value ng inner product sa pagitan ng dalawang Quantum State
vector ay palaging isang numero sa pagitan ng zero at isa at nagbibigay ito sa atin ng isang natural na paraan ng pagsukat kung gaano karaming overlap ang mayroon
sa pagitan ng dalawang Quantum State vector at maaari mong isipin ang Fidelity bilang isang kapaki-pakinabang at magandang gawi na paraan upang
palawakin ang paraang ito ng pagsukat ng overlap mula sa mga Pure state patungo sa mga density matrix kung isa sa mga estado ay pure
at ang isa pa ay hindi kinakailangang pure pagkatapos ay muli ay mayroon tayong simpleng pagpapahayag para sa Fidelity na maaaring maging medyo
maginhawa at ang pagpapahayag na iyon ay ipinapakita dito mismo ang Fidelity ay may maraming kawili-wiling
katangian at iyon ay isa sa mga dahilan kung bakit ginagamit ng mga tao ito mayroon itong isang depinisyon na hindi talaga
maganda ngunit ito ay isang napaka-kapaki-pakinabang na function kahit na at madalas na napakadaling gamitin sa bahagi dahil sa marami nitong
kahanga-hangang katangian kaya tingnan natin ang ilan sa kanila simula sa obserbasyon na ang Fidelity sa pagitan ng dalawang density
matrix ay palaging isang numero sa pagitan ng 0 at isa ito ay zero kung at tanging kung ang mga estado
ay orthogonal ibig sabihin ang mga imahe ay orthogonal na mga subspace o katumbas nito ang produkto ng dalawang matrix ay
zero at ang Fidelity ay isa kung at tanging kung ang dalawang density matrix ay pantay bawat ibang kaso ay nasa pagitan
ngunit sa intuitibong pagsasalita mas malapit ang Fidelity sa isa mas katulad ang mga estado o alternatibo
mas maraming overlap nila ang Fidelity ay simetriko rin nabanggit ko iyon kaunti lamang kanina ito ay
medyo malinaw mula sa pagpapahayag na nakita natin para sa Fidelity sa mga termino ng trace Norm ngunit ito ay isang mahalagang bagay na kilalanin
karagdagan ang Fidelity ay multiplicative para sa mga product State ibig sabihin ang Fidelity sa pagitan ng dalawang
product State ay palaging katumbas ng produkto ng mga fidelity sa pagitan ng mga indibidwal
estado narito ang isang napaka-kapaki-pakinabang na katangian kung mayroon tayong anumang dalawang density matrix ng parehong sukat
kasama ang anumang channel na kumukuha ng mga density matrix na ito bilang input ang Fidelity ay maaari lamang lumaki kapag ang channel na iyon
ay inilapat sa parehong mga estado kaya sa ibang salita sa mga termino ng Fidelity ang mga channel ay maaari lamang gawing
mas katulad ang mga estado sa isa't isa hindi nila magagawang mas hindi katulad ang mga ito at sa wakas para sa listahang ito man
ay mayroong isang medyo malapit na relasyon sa pagitan ng Fidelity at ng trace distance sa pagitan ng mga estado na tinutukoy bilang
kalahati ng trace Norm ng pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng dalawang density matrix ang trace distance sa pagitan ng dalawang
estado ay malakas na kumokonekta sa kung gaano nating mahusay na matukoy ang mga ito na tinalakay natin sa nakaraang aralin sa konteksto ng
State discrimination at ang hellstrom Holo theorem habang ang Fidelity ay nagkukuantipika kung gaano karaming overlap ang dalawang estado
kaya kahit hindi sila eksakto parehong bagay hindi nakakagulat na mayroon isang relasyon sa pagitan ng mga ito
dalawang dami ngunit sa anumang kaso ang mga hindi pagkakatumbas na ito na karaniwang tinatawag na fuk Vander graph na mga hindi pagkakatumbas
ay ginagawang tiyak na matematika ang relasyon na ito at napaka-mahalaga na walang anumang dependensya dito sa sukat ng sistema na pinag-uusapan natin
maaari nating makita ang relasyon na ito nang mas malinaw sa tulong ng isang figure kung mayroon tayong dalawang estado at
hanapin natin ang trace distance sa pagitan nila sa x-axis at ang Fidelity sa y-axis pagkatapos ay ang kaukulang patayo
at pahalang na mga linya ay dapat magtipid sa loob ng kulay-abuhing rehiyong ito ang pinaka-kawili-wiling rehiyon ng
plot sa pamamagitan ng paraan kahit sa praktikal na pagsasalita ay ang kaliwang sulok sa itaas ng kulay-abuhing rehiyon sa partikular kapag ang
trace distance ay napakaliit ang Fidelity ay dapat na napaka-malapit sa isa at kabaligtaran
ang mga hindi pagkakatumbas na ito ay ginagamit nang napakadalas at bahagi ng dahilan para doon ay madalas tayong mas nagmamalasakit sa
trace distance sa huli dahil mayroon itong natural na interpretasyon na kumokonekta sa Quantum State discrimination
ngunit ang Fidelity ay may napakaraming kahanga-hangang katangian na ito sa pangkalahatan ang mas madaling pagtrabahuhin at basta nasa kaliwang sulok sa itaas tayo ng
kulay-abuhing rehiyon na madalas na doon natin makita ang ating sarili ay hindi tayo nawawala ng masyadong marami sa pamamagitan ng pagko-convert pabalik-balik sa pagitan ng Fidelity at ng trace distance kaya iyon
ang ilan sa mga katangian ng Fidelity marami pa ngunit ito ay isang magandang simula at sana ay nakatutulong ang listahan para sa
simula ng pagbuo ng ilang intuisyon tungkol sa Fidelity narito ang isang magandang halimbawa ng kung paano natin
maaaring i-connect ang Fidelity sa mga non-destructive na sukat ito ay isang napaka-maginhawang katotohanan na kilala bilang The Gentle measurement
Lemma ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong sistema x isang estado ng X na kinakatawan ng isang density Matrix row at isang sukat sa sistema X
na inilalarawan ng isang koleksyon ng mga positive semi-definite matrix ipagpalagay natin na ang isa sa mga resulta ng sukat ay malamang na
lumabas kung susukatin natin ang estado row para sa Simplisidad ipagpalagay natin
na ito ang resulta na Z Z na malamang na lumabas at sa partikular ipagpalagay natin na ang resulta na ito ay lumalabas na may
probabilidad na mas malaki kaysa sa 1 us Epsilon para sa ilang maliit na halaga ng Epsilon na hindi talaga natin kailangang tukuyin ang Epsilon
ay isang maliit na positibong tunay na numero ngayon inilarawan namin ang aming sukat na parang ito ay isang destructive
measurement ngunit alam natin mula sa nakaraang aralin na maaari nating i-implement ang sukat na ito sa isang non-destructive na paraan at partikular maaari nating gawin ito tulad ng
nakita natin sa ating talakayan ng teorema ni Neymar at gumagana ito tulad nito ang bawat resulta a ay lumalabas na may
probabilidad na katumbas ng trace ng PA * row at naka-kondisyon sa pagkuha ng resulta na iyon ang estado ng X ay nagbabago sa
partikular sa kaso na nakukuha natin ang malamang na resulta na zero ang estado ay nagiging ang squ otk ng p 0 * row * theun ng p 0
lahat ay normalized upang makakuha tayo ng isang density Matrix at ang sinasabi sa atin ng gentle measurement limit ay na sa kaganapang ito
ibig sabihin ay talagang nakuha natin ang malamang na resulta ng sukat ang estado na nakuha natin ay hindi masyadong nagbago mula sa
orihinal at sa partikular ang Fidelity squared ay kinakailangang mas malaki kaysa sa 1 minus
Epsilon at ito ay maganda dahil ito ay ganap na pangkalahatan wala tayong sinabi tungkol sa sukat o
sa estado maliban sa isa sa mga resulta ay malamang kaya ang Lemma ay maaaring ilapat sa
maraming iba't ibang setting kung saan nais nating i-verify ang isang bagay tungkol sa isang Quantum State nang hindi masyadong nagagambala ito kaya tingnan natin kung paano natin mapatunayan
ito at para sa karamihan ay talagang isang medyo simpleng bagay ng pagkalkula ng Fidelity sa pagitan ng mga pre at postmeasurement
na estado maaari nating gawin ito sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng orihinal na depinisyon at karaniwang maaaring mag-iwan ito sa atin ng isang maagusan na formula ngunit
sa kasong ito ay mapalad tayo dahil ang bagay sa loob ng panlabas na square root ay talagang square ng isang matrix na
mangyayaring maging positive semi-definite na ginagawang trivial ang pagkalkula ng square maaari na nating gamitin ang cyclic
property ng trace kasama ang linearidad ng trace upang pasimplehin ang ating pagpapahayag tulad ng ipinapakita sa screen pansinin sa pamamagitan ng paraan na ang mga ito ay
lahat ng pagkakahalaga kaya hindi tayo nag-approximate ng anumang bagay sa puntong ito talagang pinasimple lamang natin ngunit ngayon kailangan na natin ng isang
hindi pagkakatumbas dahil gusto nating alisin ang square root sa numerator at maaari nating gawin iyon kung handa tayong sumang-ayon sa isang lower bound at kung
interesado ka sa mga detalye para sa bahaging ito maaari mong makuha ang hindi pagkakatumbas nang medyo madali sa pamamagitan ng pagsasaalang-alang ng isang spectral decomposition ng p
0 ang mga eigen value ng p 0 ay dapat na nasa pagitan ng 0 at isa iyon ay palaging totoo para sa mga matrix na naglalarawan ng
mga sukat at kapag nalaman na natin iyon ang hindi pagkakatumbas ay sumusunod nang direkta mula sa katotohanang ang pagkuha ng square root ng
isang numero sa pagitan ng 0 at isa ay maaari lamang itong gawing mas malaki ang isa pang paraan ng pagsabi nito ay ang pag-square ng isang numero sa pagitan ng Z at
isa ay maaari lamang itong gawing mas maliit maaari na nating pasimplehin nang kaunti pa at makuha natin ang square
root ng trace ng p 0 * row sa wakas ang pag-square sa magkabilang panig at
pag-plug in ng ating bound sa probabilidad ay nagbibigay sa atin ng gusto nating makuha kaya ang formula para sa Fidelity
ay hindi ang pinakamaganda o pinakamadaling gamitin na formula sa mundo ngunit dito ay gumagana ito nang medyo
maganda upang tapusin ang aralin ay titingnan natin ang teorema ni alman na isang pundamental na katotohanan tungkol sa Fidelity na
nag-uugnay nito sa konsepto ng purification ang sinasabi ng teorema sa simpleng mga termino ay ang Fidelity sa pagitan ng anumang dalawang
Quantum State ay katumbas ng maximum inner product sa absolute value sa pagitan ng dalawang purification ng mga
estado na iyon sa kaunting mas detalye ipagpalagay na ang row at sigma ay mga density matrix para sa ilang sistema X at ipagpalagay na ang Y ay isang
sistema na may hindi bababa sa kasingyaman ng mga classical State gaya ng X at samakatuwid ay garantisado na ang parehong mga estado na ito ay may mga purification na
quantum State vector ng XY maaari nating ipahayag ang implikasyon ng teorema sa anyo ng equation
na ipinapakita sa screen ang Fidelity sa pagitan ng row at sigma ay katumbas ng maximum absolute value ng inner product
sa pagitan ng F at SII na sumasaklaw sa lahat ng fi at S na nag-purify ng row at sigma
ayon sa pagkakasunud-sunod kaya linisin natin ito at magtrabaho gamit ang tiyak na mathematical na pahayag na sumusulong ang gagawin natin ngayon ay patunayan
ang teorema ngunit una ay kapaki-pakinabang na maglaan ng sandali upang pahalagahan na nagbibigay ito sa atin ng medyo intuitive na paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa
Fidelity kapaki-pakinabang din ito sa sarili nito halimbawa upang mapatunayan ang mas kawili-wiling mga bagay tungkol sa
Fidelity upang mapatunayan ito ay magsisimula tayo sa mga spectral decomposition ng ating density
matrices walang mga sorpresa doon kapag mayroon na tayong mga spectral decomposition madali itong makabuo ng
dalawang tiyak na purification ng mga estadong ito ngunit dito ay talagang gagawa tayo ng isang
trick pansinin na sa parehong kaso ay wala tayong standard basis VOR bilang pangalawang tensor Factor tulad ng ginawa natin kanina sa
aralin ngunit sa halip ay mayroon tayong parehong Vector gaya ng sa unang tensor Factor maliban na ito ay may bar sa ibabaw nito at
ibig sabihin nito ang entry-wise complex conjugate ng mga vector na ito kaya sa ibang salita karaniwang kinukuha lamang natin ang isang
pangalawang kopya ng mga eigen vector ngunit kinukuha natin ang complex conjugate ng bawat entry at makikita natin kung bakit natin ginagawa iyon sa ilang
sandali ngunit hindi halatang dapat nating gawin ito at iyon ang dahilan kung bakit tinatawag natin itong isang
trick sa anumang kaso ang mga ito ay mga purification ng row at sigma ayon sa pagkakasunud-sunod at iyon ay totoo dahil sa
katotohanang ang ating mga eigen vector ay orthonormal at samakatuwid gayon din ang kanilang mga entry-wise complex conjugate at ngayon maaari nating ilapat ang
unitary equivalence ng mga purification na nagsasabing ang bawat purification ng ating dalawang estado ay maaaring makuha sa pamamagitan ng
pag-apply ng isang unitary operation sa sistema na na-trace out para sa mga tiyak na pagpipilian ng mga purification na
katatapos natin gawin ang mga unitary operation ay hindi kailangang pareho para sa dalawang purification
siyempre kaya dito ginagamit natin ang titik U para sa una at ang titik V para sa pangalawa
kaya ang punto ay ang bawat purification ng ating dalawang estado ay maaaring isulat tulad ng nasa screen para sa
ilang pagpipilian ng mga unitary operation u at v at ngayon maaari nating kunin ang pagpapahayag
mula sa teorema at pasimplehin kung ii-plug in natin ang ating mga pagpapahayag para sa F at S at pasimplehin nang kaunti ay
makuha natin ang pagpapahayag na ipinapakita dito sa screen ngayon ay may ilang mga hakbang doon at hindi ko ipinakita ang mga detalye
kaya alam mo na ang gagawin kung gusto mong gawin ito ngunit banggitin ko na ang dahilan kung bakit pinili natin ang mga purification tulad ng ginawa natin
ay upang payagan ang inner product na ito na pasimplehin sa eksakto sa ganitong paraan at sa partikular ay inilagay natin ang mga complex conjugate
doon upang epektibong maka-flip tayo sa paligid ng mga inner product sa pangalawang tensor factor upang makuha ang tiyak
na anyo na mayroon tayo ngayon halos nandoon na tayo ngayon maaari nating gamitin ang cyclic property ng trace kasama
ang mga spectral decomposition na sinimulan natin upang makuha ang pagpapahayag na ito at sa puntong ito ay maaari nating
gamitin ang isa sa mga alternatibong paraan ng pagpapahayag ng Fidelity gamit ang trace norm at
tapos na tayo tiyak mayroong mga detalye doon na mabilis kong nilaktawan at ito ang uri ng patunay na
talagang kailangan mong pagtrabahuhin mismo upang ganap na maunawaan ngunit sana ay nagbibigay ito sa iyo ng pangunahing
ideya at tulad ng dati maaari kang makahanap ng mas maraming detalye sa nakasulat na nilalaman para sa aralin na naka-link sa video
at tulad ng dati maaari kang makahanap ng mas maraming detalye sa nakasulat na nilalaman para sa aralin na naka-link sa video
description at iyon ang katapusan ng aralin na tungkol sa mga purification, Fidelity at mga koneksyon sa pagitan ng mga ito at ito rin ang
katapusan ng yunit na tungkol sa pangkalahatang pormulasyon ng Quantum na impormasyon umaasa akong sasali ka sa akin para sa
ikaapat at huling yunit ng serye na tungkol sa Quantum error correction salamat sa panonood